tout de suite vu de Russie
bienvenue dans vue de Russie le magazine
hebdomadaire qui analyse à propagande de
Vladimir Poutine sur fond de guerre en
Ukraine avec Elena Volochine bonsoir
Elena bonsoir Stéphanie et ce soir vous
revenez sur l'attentat on s'en souvient
contre un blogueur russe proguer c'était
dimanche dernier dans un bar de
Saint-Pétersbourg oui ce soir là un club
de discussion est réuni dans ce bar
lorsque ce produit une explosion il y
aura 42 blessés et un mort Maxime Fomine
l'invité principale de la soirée vous
allez voir les images plus connues sous
le pseudonyme de vladline Tatarski il
était ce qu'on appelle en Russie un
vaïen call un correspondant de guerre un
correspondant proguer pour être plus
précis sur sa chaîne télégram qui compte
plus de 500 000 abonnés il soutenait
activement la guerre de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine il a d'ailleurs lui-même
combattu en tant que droniste au sein
des bataillons de la République
autoproclamés prorus de donuts dites DNR
cette entité à l'est de l'Ukraine qui
dès 2014 sous l'égide de la Russie a
fait sécession du reste du pays en 2022
il est retourné au front pour participer
notamment à la prise de Mario Paul au
lendemain de sa mort le journal télévisé
de la chaîne Russia 1 l'une des deux
principales chaînes du pays lui rendent
hommage regardez
ce soir à Moscou les gens déposent des
fleurs à l'ambassade de la DNR devant le
portrait de Maxime Fomine connu de tous
comme le journaliste et combattant
vladen tattarski en star il était l'un
des correspondants de guerre les plus
célèbres du pays les militaires tout
comme ses collègues journalistes le
considérait comme l'un des leurs sons
inspiré le respect et son dévouement
permettait de résoudre de nombreux
problèmes sérieuses pour cela ceux qui
combattaient tout comme ceux qui
apprenaient les dernières nouvelles du
front grâce à lui lui sont
reconnaissants donc la victime est
présentée comme un journaliste sérieux
et dévoué Elena Poutine là aussi décorée
de l'Ordre du courage être posthume et
les officiels russes lui ont aussi rendu
hommage oui du patriarche qui rit le
porte-parole de Vladimir Poutine ou
encore de la du ministère russe des
Affaires étrangères tout son salués sont
professionnels en tant que journaliste
et son dévouement pour informer en
accusant aussi tour à tour les opposants
russes l'Ukraine ou encore les
Occidentaux d'avoir commandité cette
attentat le plus le plus virulent pardon
a été comme souvent admis il est
aujourd'hui on le rappelle chef adjoint
du Conseil de sécurité de la Fédération
de Russie voici ce qu'il a écrit sur sa
chaîne à telegram regardez on l'a
traduit et doublé pour vous
oui oui c'est notre soi-disant
opposition irréductible qui fait la
guerre à son propre pays depuis de
nombreuses années déjà avec le soutien
actif de l'Occident tous ces puants
Navalny rodorkowski volcov sont devenus
des terroristes et des assassins
notoires il se délectent passionnément à
la vue du sang des citoyens de la Russie
il gonfle le narines d'excitation à la
vue des blessés et des corps mutilés ils
ont prêté allégeance au ténèbres et à la
terreur avec les assassins de leur chair
régime nazi de Kiev on ne négocie pas
avec les terroristes on les extermine
comme des chiens enragés avec leur bave
vénéneuse coulant de leur bouche
qui est chef adjoint du Conseil de
sécurité de Russie Elena il appelle on
vient de l'entendre à exterminer les
opposants russes Alexa
est en prison il est déjà en prison on
sait il a fait par le passé l'objet
d'une tentative d'assassinat par les
services secrets russes et de son côté
donc Maxime Fomine alias vladen tapaski
a donc perdu la vie dans l'attentat de
dimanche dernier et lui appelait à
exterminer les Ukrainiens oui il était
parmi les propagandistes les plus
radicaux du régime de Vladimir poutini
la plaie régulièrement effectivement à
exterminer l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens
il est désigné comme les pores et les je
prononce ce mot en russe car c'est une
insulte intraduisible pour dire
ukrainien et c'est important de
l'entendre parce que vous pourrez
comprendre ce que faux mine en fait
disait dans ses vidéos regarder des
extraits
Portland cet état terroriste et
démoniaque peuplé d'une foule de
dégénéré ayant perdu l'esprit
c'est une infanterie d'acier ils
détiennent le record de tuerie des rares
à eux l'Ukraine est un état démoniaque
on doit en finir avec cet état tôt ou
tard les
Ukrainiens sont des transvestimaux ils
parlent russe leur grand-père ont
combattu dans l'armée rouge mais on leur
dit non ce sont des foutais ce n'est
rien d'autre que l'influence
impérialiste de la Russie et de l'URSS
voilà donc une négation de l'Ukraine en
tant qu'État et des Ukrainiens en tant
que peuple et de la des appels à les
détruire plus choquant encore et on l'a
vu un peu avec ses hommages
d'officielles russes non seulement
maxime fomin n'a jamais été poursuivi
pour extrémisme mais ses propos
entraient parfaitement en fait en
résonance avec l'idéologie de Vladimir
Poutine dans sa guerre contre l'Ukraine
vomit d'ailleurs il intervenait
régulièrement en tant que consultant
auprès des officiels et des institutions
russes il y a quelques jours un autre
propagandiste russe Alexa roudenko il a
posté sur sa chaîne télégram une vidéo
vous voyez ces images ou Maxime Fomine
intervenait devant des soldats de la
Garde nationale russe il participe ses
soldats au combat en Ukraine et il les
conseille notamment fominent sur comment
mener la guerre informationnelle et
comment se comporter lorsqu'ils sont en
Ukraine auprès des populations de ces
territoires que la Russie occupe cette
vidéo est la par la suite était effacée
puisqu'elle n'avait pas vocation à fuer
bien entendu la caméra ne montrera
jamais le public ces soldats de la garde
nationale regardez donc cette réunion de
travail entre la garde nationale et
Maxime Fomine c'était différent
si au début de la guerre notre
propagande avait été plus agressive je
suis sûr qu'on sera rentré en Ukraine
comme dans du beurre
la guerre informationnelle est
importante car nous devons porter un
coup au cerveau le cerveau de l'ennemi
nous aurons fatigués de tuer des
Ukrainiens ça fait un an qu'on fait la
guerre et on en a neutralisé que 500 000
il nous faudra encore combien d'années
pour les tuer tous
indubitablement nos victoires militaires
doivent être accompagnées d'opérations
psychologiques
nous allons là-bas pour mettre de
l'ordre chasser les nationalistes pour
la démilitarisation et la dénazification
mais comment peut-on toucher l'auditoire
en Ukraine
notre victoire militaire doit aller de
père avec une victoire psychologique les
rally sont des sauvages les peuples
sauvages ne comprennent pas les
délicatesses philosophiques ni ce qu'on
a à leur offrir
vous ne gagnerez votre auditoire qu'à
travers des actions violentes de la part
du soldat russe et la mer ou la veuve a
pleuré du soldat tué dira aux autres
fais attention sinon les Russes
viendront
donc plus t'es violents
plus on dirait que le russe est fort
qui explique probablement les crimes de
guerre commis par les soldats russes en
Ukraine ses discours sont banalisés en
Russie oui tout à fait revenons
d'ailleurs sur cet événement dans ce bar
où il y a eu cette attentat dimanche
dernier lorsque Maxime fourmi a été tué
avec Karina chabour bonsoir Karina merci
beaucoup de nous faire des gentillesse
de ce passage dans vue de Russie je vous
ai invité parce que justement dans ce
fameux bar où a eu lieu l'explosion vous
avez tourné pour France 24 on va voir
vos images sur les écrans alors
racontez-nous à qui il appartient ce bar
et qu'est-ce qui s'y passait comme
événement alors on le voit c'est un très
grand bar restaurant dans le centre
historique de Saint-Pétersbourg donc je
m'y étais rendue en juin dernier pour
rencontrer donc des membres de cyber
frontzed qui est un collectif qui occupe
ce bar tous les week-ends du vendredi
soir jusqu'au dimanche soir ils l'ont
d'ailleurs rebaptisé le patriote barre
et cyber Franz et bien c'est un
collectif qui est né sur telegram pour
précisément mener guerre de
l'information pour diffuser des
commentaires en faveur de ce qu'ils
appellent l'opération spéciale et pour
et bien dénigrer tous les commentaires
négatifs de cette guerre menée par
Vladimir Poutine en Ukraine alors leurs
arguments c'est toujours les mêmes un
Ukraine les Ukrainiens n'ont jamais
respecté le cesser le feu dans le Dombas
ce sont des des nazis qui s'en prennent
aussi ville et comme j'étais française
et bien opportunément ce jour-là leur
cible c'était le président Macron et
donc d'envoyer pendant toute
l'après-midi des commentaires sur tous
les réseaux sociaux du président
français pour le dissuader de livrer des
armes des canons César à l'Ukraine et
dans la soirée et bien c'était une
soirée débat comme vous le disiez avec
des essayistes un des séismes en
particulier de cette mouvance on va dire
très nationaliste très proguer très
conservatrice oui donc et leur c'est un
peu une un dérivé finalement de cette
usine à troll que l'on connaissait déjà
qui appartient à ifgani Prigogine le de
la milice militaire privée Wagner et non
seulement ils écrivaient des
commentaires mais ils étaient aussi
chargés de la délation auprès des
services secrets russes de ces fameuses
opposants que de mitry-méda donc appel à
exterminer mais c'est une toute autre
image qu'il voulait donner au public
Carina est-ce que vous pouvez nous
décrire un peu l'ambiance comment il se
présentait ces gens qu'elle était leur
image visée des médias effectivement on
le voit bien sur l'image ils sont jeunes
plutôt la trentaine vingtaine parfois en
jean en basket en casquette et tous
disent pour la plupart travailler dans
le numérique et venir dans ce bar tous
les week-ends sur leur temps libre pour
par amour de la patrie pour se rendre
utile mais aussi parfois pour rencontrer
précisément des blogueurs très influents
ils étaient plutôt accueillants ils
m'ont laissé filmer ils nous ont répondu
à mes questions sauf à une seule qui
était de savoir à qui appartient ce bar
silence là-dessus même embarras dans la
salle et c'est en volant un ticket de
caisse que j'ai pu comprendre que ça
appartenait effectivement au Concorde
groupe d'evgani Prigogine Mania de la
restauration Mania de la désinformation
et qui est connu aujourd'hui comme étant
le dirigeant de cette armée de
mercenaires Wagner et je me suis donc
rendu compte que la plupart de ces
jeunes en fait étaient payés travaillés
pour l'usine à troll de yefghani
Prigogine pour inonder la toile de ses
commentaires pro opérations spéciales
merci beaucoup Karina elle ne voulait
pas vous dire à l'époque il travaillait
pour Prigogine parce que Prigogine est
sorti de l'ombre au cours de la guerre
pendant cette fameuse opération spéciale
comme l'appel Vladimir Poutine il combat
aujourd'hui à barmouth mais il est venu
dans ce bar sur les ruines de ce bar au
lendemain de l'attentat et vous allez
l'entendre il promet un nouvel élan au
cyber front Z
iege
j'estime que malgré la mort de Madeleine
Tatarski et malgré toutes ces situations
tragiques cyber front Z doit obtenir un
nouvel élan un nouveau souffle et se
transformer en une vraie organisation
citoyenne
mais on peut dire que les discours de
haine elles ont encore de beaux jours
devant eux en Russie oui et d'ailleurs
cyber fronza a annoncé son prochain
événement dans le Wagner Center à
Saint-Pétersbourg ce sera pas plus tard
qu'après demain ce dimanche et côté
ukrainien le conseiller du président
ukrainien vous le Dimir Zelinski
il a écrit sur Twitter et il a réagi à
cet attentat cela commence en Russie les
araignées se mangent entre elles dans le
vase voilà pour ces propos pour ce qui
est des pistes la police russe a pour
leur arrêter inculper une jeune femme de
26 ans l'activiste antiguer Daria
trepova accusé d'avoir offert à Maxime
Fomine la statuette qui aurait explosé
mais les circonstances exactes de cette
attentat et c'est commanditaire demeure
pour leur indéterminée merci Elena et
c'est tout pour vue de Russie on se
retrouve vendredi prochain